in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Mario
and Ashley are with us hey guys how are
you today better than we deserve I love
it welcome
where are you guys from st. Genevieve
Missouri Oh fun
good to have you so you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir and how
much have you paid off ninety-three
thousand all right and how long did that
take four months thirty four months and
your range of income during that time we
started at 32,000 and this year we
should finish around 150 oh there's a
story there oh my gosh in three years
you fivefold your income okay so tell me
about that well it all started my
sister-in-law actually offered us your
DVD an audio book and I took it and
everyday to work I listen to it listen
to it and I got really inspired and I
just kind of I jumped into it and I
wanted to you know I wanted to do it and
so I brought it to Ashley's yep and at
that time after he gave it to me I was
really excited and but we had a problem
I was still in nursing school and oh you
come on our school that's part of the
income okay yeah kind of
so for the next year we kind of just we
did what we called debt snowball ish you
know I was more of the schemer
I figure out how I wanted to do things
and I would make it happen no matter
what that meant and then I got it I got
my first nursing job I was working in
our little town Hospital and trucking
along making you know okay income and um
some of my co-workers they were
listening to your radio show and I was
like hey yeah I know this guy
we tried it you know it wasn't really
going and the more we looked at it we
thought okay we can do this so I
actually signed up for your my Total
Money Makeover online budgeting at that
time and I got got going with that and I
was had our first budget all set and
then Mario got laid off the first the
first day of starting this - of course
yeah right
so you know what would have normally
been my reaction would been okay let me
figure out where I can borrow money from
what can I do and instead of doing that
you know I trusted God and I said you
know you brought us to this point and
you're gonna be there with us no matter
what and I got another job and you know
we got through it and he was ended up
only being laid off for like three weeks
so so you came out of school and became
a full-time nurse and then and probably
extra hours on that as well yeah and
Mario what are you doing now I'm a
quality control technician in a rock
quarry
okay and I mean basically after you know
being laid off for three weeks we we
prayed and we prayed and we ask God for
work and he provided the work and I went
into 80 hours a week working night shift
and there it was and you know we we
jumped into it and we started selling
right and left I mean what we didn't
need you know what did what was the
hardest thing that you sold I would say
I think there was an ouch
I would say probably some of my tools
and it was I mean it was I just had to
do it I had to do something I had to
make a move yeah and you know so what
kind of debt was the ninety three
thousand well we had everything the
biggest chunk of it was school loans
the sad part about that really is you
know you think school loans and it's all
supposed to be for school but I mean
that was what we lived on because as a
nurse I believed a lot of the lies that
when you get out of nursing school you
can get in these programs that are gonna
take care of you and that's not you know
for the you know for the majority of us
that's not true so we had over $50,000
in school loans car truck lines of
credit medical bills credit cards yep so
for three years basically almost thirty
four months you guys have been busting
it I mean I hear to 80 hour weeks going
here oh yeah yeah you just been gone
like all the time yeah so how's it feel
though now that you did it
freeing liberating we're not slaves
anymore yeah exactly
there's no pressure no I mean you were
making 32,000 and you're broke and
deeply in debt now you make 150,000 and
you don't have any debt yeah it's a
completely different world as you see
the world in a different view yeah
really do and Buddy don't ask God for
work because he'll give it to you we're
just gonna make sure that's good but it
worked I mean that's the way you do it
you how do you get out of that you work
that's what you did and you guys weren't
afraid of that that work ethic is
amazing so and the good news is you've
worked like no one else now you can work
like no one else you do very cool well
congratulations you guys and you got the
three kids with you what are their names
and ages we have summer Serena and
Sophie sixteen twelve and eight all
right who also have they been practicing
all the way from Missouri yeah pretty
much we know how to do a debt free
screaming right yeah yeah okay very cool
good all right it's Mario and actually
summer Serina and Sophie st. Louis
Missouri
$93,000 paid off in 34 months by the way
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book as a part of this so that
because it's the next chapter for you to
live like no one else and become wealthy
and be incredibly generous they did all
this starting at 32 now making a hundred
and fifty thousand work in a bazillion
hours count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
way to go you guys very very very well
done very proud of you
excellent job man that is so cool work
their tails off how you get out of debt
you work your tail off that's how you do
it
not like you know I'm gonna worked 14
hours no it's like 14 hours today hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a $500,000
in the car